[Music]
85% of the matter in our universe is a
mystery we don't know what it's made of
which is why we call it dark matter but
we know it's out there because we can
observe its gravitational attraction on
galaxies and other celestial objects
we've yet to directly observe dark
matter but scientists theorize that we
may actually be able to create it in the
most powerful particle collider in the
world
that's the twenty seven kilometer long
Large Hadron Collider or LHC in Geneva
Switzerland so how would that work in
the LHC two proton beams move in
opposite directions and are accelerated
to near the speed of light at for
collision points the beams cross and
protons smash into each other protons
are made of much smaller components
called quarks and gluons in most
ordinary collisions the two protons pass
through each other without any
significant outcome however in about one
in a million collisions two components
hit each other so violently that most of
the collision energy is set free
producing thousands of new particles
it's only in these collisions that very
massive particles like the theorized
Dark Matter can be produced the
collision points are surrounded by
detectors containing about 100 million
sensors like huge three-dimensional
cameras they gather information on those
new particles including their trajectory
electrical charge and energy once
processed the computers can depict a
collision as an image each line is the
path of a different particle and
different types of particles are
color-coded data from the detectors
allows scientists to determine what each
of these particles is things like
photons and electrons now the detectors
take snapshots of about a billion of
these collisions per second to find
signs of extremely rare
massive particles to add to the
difficulty the particles we're looking
for may be unstable and decay into more
familiar particles before reaching the
sensors
take for example the Higgs boson a long
theorized particle that wasn't observed
until 2012 the odds of a given collision
producing a Higgs boson are about one in
10 billion and it only lasts for a tiny
fraction of a second before decaying but
scientists develop theoretical models to
tell them what to look for for the Higgs
they thought it would sometimes decay
into two photons so they first examined
only the high-energy events that
included two photons but there's a
problem here there are innumerable
particle interactions that can produce
two random photons so how do you
separate out the Higgs from everything
else
the answer is mass the information
gathered by the detectors it allows the
scientists to go a step back and
determine the mass of whatever it was
that produced two photons they put that
mass value into a graph and then repeat
the process for all events with two
photons the vast majority of these
events are just random photon
observations what scientists call
background events but when a Higgs boson
is produced and decays into two photons
the mass always comes out to be the same
therefore the tell-tale sign of the
Higgs boson would be a little bump
sitting on top of the background it
takes billions of observations before a
bump like this can appear and it's only
considered a meaningful result if that
bump becomes significantly higher than
the background
in the case of the Higgs boson the
scientists at the LHC announced their
groundbreaking results when there was
only a one in three million chance this
bump could have appeared by a
statistical fluke so back to the dark
matter if the LHC's proton beams have
enough energy to produce it that's
probably an even rarer occurrence than
the Higgs boson
so it takes quadrillions of collisions
combined with theoretical models to even
start to look that's what the LHC is
currently doing by generating a mountain
of data we're hoping to find more tiny
bumps in graphs that will provide
evidence for yet unknown particles like
dark matter or maybe what we'll find
won't be dark matter but something else
that would reshape our understanding of
how the universe works entirely that's
part of the fun at this point we have no
idea what we're going to find every TED
ed video you've seen is the result of
many months of hard work from people all
over the world
for example this quirky video about
particle physics was a collaboration
between the ted-ed team a scientists at
CERN a handful of script editors in New
York and an animator in the UK and now
after five months of creative collisions
the video exists and it's free for you
and everyone else in the world to learn
from and to share forever as our channel
grows we'd love to take on bigger and
older collaborations but ted-ed is a
non-profit so we can't do that without a
little extra help so if you enjoy ted-ed
videos please help us make more of them
by supporting our work on patreon.com
slash ted-ed
as always thanks for watching
[Music]